so a necessary death premiered at south
by southwest in 2008 and since then you
went out and made the last exorcism at
least
so why is necessary death now they are
loose
well it was we had the same offer from
film buff who's now our distributor in
2008 was met dendler who was the head of
south by southwest of retirement program
necessary death reports from yourself
back then went to film buff and
necessary death wasn't personally become
took with them and said or made the
offer and I was too arrogant back then
because I still thought that we might
have a shot at a theatrical release you
know so I didn't wanna go VOD
immediately I thought we could still you
know and then whenever when last
exorcism came around we said let's see
how that movie does and if that does
well maybe we get some momentum for
necessary death from them of course we
never went theatrical and always and
everyone around me knew that but they
were all too diplomatic and too nice to
actually tell me that that we've never
even met dan frozen okay I'll wait and
he knew exactly that a couple of years
later I would come back and go on it
gets to the DVD and VOD really and then
I was insisting on the DVD release every
said you don't need a DVD release
because deg is dead and the future is
VOD but i'm just still a child from that
old fashioned time when you want your
movie in a little discs were there on
the desk with box around it and i think
they just did that to you marina dramas
are here will give you the DVD but we're
really interested in the VOD side of
things and i didn't really care for a
VOD side of things so now we're doing
DVD and VOD but i think a lot more
people are actually streaming and
downloading the trouble and buying the
DVD which they shouldn't because there
are beautiful special features on the
DVD 30 minutes of extra material or
alternate ending all that kind of stuff
so still get a lot of stuff with the
actual DVD but i think i'm by preaching
to to an audience that doesn't exist
anymore cuz no advise vin diesel
with the theatrical did you actually
call some leaders yourself and try to
for some reason that always felt to me I
needed that if you've made a movie as
low fire as we did I wanted that that
stamp of approval and of an official no
no you've made a film you know you're
not you're not taking a YouTube style
video and now putting it in a theater
that you pay for yourself I wanted a
real distributor for the accuracy
because I didn't hang them for their
work for three years and I needed for
them I needed this project to have some
official stamp of approval and you've
made an actual movie and for some reason
that to me and my mind was defined by
finding a distributor who's willing to
invest in and put out the DVD without me
putting my money it and also don't have
the head for self distributing I think I
have a lot of respect for people that
can organize that kind of stuff I don't
think I could I don't have the patience
or the courage or any of it it just
requires a whole different part of your
brain I think
didn't want to occupy myself
you